thank you with the glory of being
nominated it's important to note that
there was a time in the making of each
of these movies when all those
surrounding the director thought that he
was doing it absolutely wrong is the
nature of directing to be second-guessed
it's the nature of the director to
wonder if anyone will care about the
things that he has cared about for so
long we do care and tonight's
nominations are the clear signal that we
could send to you I almost open it the
nominees are John Singleton the boys in
the hood Barry Levinson for Bugsy
Oliver Stone for JFK
Jonathan Demi for Silence of the Lambs
Ridley Scott for thumbin Louise
the Oscar goes to - Jonathan Demi Prasad
arms
well in the in the context of my movie
loving life this is very unanticipated
it's a the only way I can really
understand this is to recognize that I
had the great good fortune to have a
chance to work with Ted tallies great
adaptation of Thomas Harris's
extraordinarily moral and an amazing
book and to have the the good fortune to
work with the likes of tak Fujimoto and
Chrissy Zia Craig McKay and Tommy
Fleischman and Chris Newman and Howard
Shore and Howard fewer and Billy Miller
and and everybody I'm and the the the
and also to to be able to to to work
with such an ensemble cast of actors
that with Jodi and Tony of course and
and also Ted Levine for his
exceptionally courageous performance as
Jame Gumb
and Scott Glenn and Anthony healed and
and Brooke Smith and and diane baker and
and all the other wonderful actors um i
also that's won't take forever sorry
i also had the the extraordinary good
fortune to have have been embraced by by
Orion Pictures at a time which unlike
this this amazing peak moment of my life
I was at a kind of a low Valley moment
when when the Mike Medavoy and bill
Bernstein and an Arthur Krim and Eric
Glasgow kind of reached out to me and
encouraged me and and and and helped
create a home for for my collaborators
and myself and we made some movies for
them and and and and when never forget
when Mike Medavoy said I think there's a
book you might be interested in I'll
send it over and it's it's obviously I
know everybody feels the the
extraordinary irony of what's what's
happened this terrible thing that's
happened to Orion
at a moment that of re-emergence that
included Silence of the Lambs and many
other things and one thing anyway two
other quick things I'm sorry to say
that's almost one just about directing I
wanted very much to salute John
Singleton and Maddie rich and Jodie
Foster and and Ernest Dickerson and a
bunch of new people than last year that
have come on with with very exciting
wonderful visions and really breathe the
tremendously important new life and into
our whole cinematic landscape and I
really want to salute those people very
strongly
I also want to very very quickly I had
the good fortune of being uh encouraged
and and and the briefed by two great
American filmmakers who are no longer
with us and I very much I'm thrilled to
be able to invoke the the recent memory
of two great men two great filmmakers
Hal Ashby and Martin Ritt who were
really really wonderful to me and
finally and I obviously got to say hi
mom you and and thanks for transferring
your love of movies to me and thanks dad
for making me think I could actually be
part of this industry and thank you